to fertility clinics face a barrage of
complaints including at least one
lawsuit over equipment failure failures
rather that may have ruined thousands of
frozen embryos and eggs the clinics in
San Francisco and Cleveland both say the
storage tanks did not keep specimens
that the required super cold
temperatures for several hours or dr.
taryn irulu is with us Tara good morning
this is very devastating news for
thousands of people
it definitely is good morning to you
it's incredibly rare for these nitrogen
storage tanks to fail let alone at two
clinics on the same day so far neither
hospital has been able to determine
whether it was mechanical or human error
that put thousands of embryos at risk I
think that there's just a lot of anger
and hurt in the infertility community
right now about this when we spoke to
Elliot and amber ash last week they were
devastated that their frozen embryos at
a huija medical center outside Cleveland
might be destroyed in a class-action
lawsuit they allege the hospital failed
to maintain inspect monitor and/or test
their liquid nitrogen storage tanks and
call the hospital's response in utter
breach of trust the family also says the
hospital did not notify them of the
issue for nearly a week to find out that
your potential children don't exist
anymore
through media is it's absurd we are
conducting a deep investigation
University Hospitals which runs the
fertility clinic released a statement
apologizing for the incident and
promising to help patients in any way
possible this wasn't the only fertility
clinic to experience problems a nitrogen
storage container at Pacific fertility
Center in California also malfunctioned
on March 4th putting thousands of frozen
embryos and eggs in danger this is
incredibly rare dr. Peter clot ski runs
a different clinic in California and
says if the temperature rises above
minus 130 degrees Celsius the cells are
at risk this is a advance
advanced technology whenever you employ
a really advanced technology there is
always going to be risk when you're
dealing with a singular cell there's no
room for error University Hospitals told
us any lawsuits being filed will have no
bearing on the independent review being
conducted in a statement this morning
Pacific fertility Center apologized for
the anxiety the malfunction caused and
says our patients and the safety of
their eggs and embryos are our highest
priorities and we are reaching out to
inform them of this incident many women
who go through cancer treatment and they
right before their the chemotherapy they
deliver get all these eggs out so they
can later have a baby or they donated
when they were already older and now
they're too old to give their eggs or
they have lost their ovaries I mean
there are a lot of scenarios where this
is endgame for a lot of families all
right dr. nila thank you